humph comras my name is Pierre welcome
to Wed and flare let's play so there's a
special twist for this game I'm not
gonna spoil it but let's find it out oh
my freaking God I am so [ __ ] scared
right now that bed was not comfortable
oh god why is my breasts tender what
happened last night
alcohol oh my god who did I sleep with
this is a Shrek game I feel like Shrek
it's gonna come out of the closet or
some [ __ ]
awesome notes let's read them press e to
manipulate an abject whoa hello let's
burn this book this is evidence no one
will know what happened this night you
need a key
don't tell me what to do door there you
go there you go we have the king can I
leave now
alright so apparently once you close the
door in this game and open it a gun it
will change
nevermind well [ __ ] I thought that was
the point of this game but what that's a
nice job bloody feet done she should
always close door behind you it may help
you progress Ning oh my god it Shh it's
that book flying god damn you do cute
book you don't blind my services hi
plenty how you'd hide in their pets so
um do you know what happened last night
you had you were pretty wasted
I'll get damn it oh god Shrek I said you
Shrek please please it was a one-time
thing
Oh God there may be more behind a shut
door than just another wooden floor
goddamned Shrek that illiterate bastard
all right I don't know what to say he
has a great ass I just get tempted does
not move shut up door you don't know me
oh now I can do it now what what what
the foot oh my god it eh oh hello you're
not Shrek what do we got more alcohol
god damn it how wasted was I last night
please do visit me again god dammit
Shrek it was a one why my thing oh god
what was that
did I not close the doors at it what was
that oh my god oh my freaking God maybe
now we can go in here well [ __ ] you then
oh my god it did change Oh what God my
brain and Disick's platted holy [ __ ]
what is love baby don't hurt me please
ahh what did I say what did I say god
dammit love who would lead a popper next
to a candlelight you can start a fire
seriously
man this game is ultra spooks mm my mind
is just [ __ ] up bruh oh god what's
going on Oh God hello did someone like
the door huh do you sometimes feel like
going the wrong way no Shrek I'm not
like that just not what Han what your
SAP does not matter oh my god what is
going calm down calm down
combat Bruce it's a game don't look so
scared Jesus this is some no good hello
who did that okay okay oh jesus oh Jesus
Christ oh Jesus Christ
alright let me look at this let me look
at flashlight how about a flashlight you
know what I love flashlights alright
let's just be careful careful get burn
all right Brad we're fine we're fine oh
my god you're so scared I'm not even
scared oh god [ __ ] me oh god [ __ ] me
[ __ ] that [ __ ] everyone I'm so [ __ ]
Rose hold me oh god what is that Oh God
hello they said [ __ ] a pocket Amaka
god damnit it must be the spirit of
track okay do you like my book boobs
yeah I guess pieces they're pretty fat
and luscious what am I supposed to say
does not move it's that must be a hunt
it must be and oh my good oh my god sure
um oh my god when I get goose bumps I
get so itchy that I just want a quack
Hardman oh my oh my god oh my god what
is it this room is a upside-down
okay do I like the books no I don't I
just want to go home okay just wanna go
oh what am i doing in my life I don't
know how to practice in this game I
don't know I'm clicking you and I
clicking you and you and you and you and
me forever in history I don't know I'm
really really really really really
really what am I supposed to do with the
Sequoias or what is that
what did what is what was that thank you
thank you what happened it was I
appreciate it thank you now that I
opened the door something where whoa it
didn't change anything oh my god
jumping I'm bunny I'm a kangaroo
[ __ ] I'm a kangaroo
[ __ ] ain't nobody scale good
guru so now we mother of dick stains in
my face instead of kangaroo though what
the [ __ ] how am I supposed to find that
is it is that yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh my
[ __ ] do you see how dark this game is
not racist I'm just saying it's [ __ ]
black my [ __ ] god jesus [ __ ]
christ what do you think what the other
side what the [ __ ] a budget man all
right you know what I'm a closi I don't
I am done with it Oh job got a fight
whatcha paintings go for that's afraid
of your paintings I thought paintings
since the first all right what do you
want your [ __ ] [ __ ] phone man
oh that gave me a tiny heart attack
my body just froze for a second do you
ever feel like you hide in a wardrobe
yeah sure no way night dripping further
win oh my god this looks different from
what I've seen oh man stop it stop it
the noise oh my god thinks of change oh
god what is happening out there what is
this game uh uh doors tell me [ __ ] keys
on walls sounded that I don't like and
Shrek wants to make love to me I'll god
damn it Shrek mr. scherk is trying to
open a new dimension and I got it
I didn't think it was that crazy they
must be stamped I must find him and take
him home country roads all right happy
hour then all right it's rising I'm
Nisha when you have to look into every
[ __ ] little drawer for alright then
huh thank you
I found the key everyone I found the key
now where it goes here Oh gah what was
that what was that what was that it's so
dark in here I don't like it hello hello
Bros is that you doing it oh god I fell
him - oh God
don't fall into infinity Prez don't
worry my platforming skills are
impeccable look at this [ __ ] whoa yeah
[ __ ] don't scare me with lightning I
ain't afraid that [ __ ] do you think I'm
a [ __ ] do you think I get [ __ ] why can
I jump here what's the matter with you
[ __ ] [ __ ] where do we go now there
was another platform here a second ago I
swear of it oh there this I got you I'm
on it
yes all right all right don't [ __ ] this
up heads don't [ __ ] this up how far am I
supposed to jump here is that exactly
I'm jumping there oh god I should not
have done that back on the chairs fine
all right you know what breasts okay
maybe I lied maybe now no I'm not a 360
no-scope urn but you know what I can
dream okay where's my [ __ ] floor I
specifically ordered floor oh my god I
randomly jab down oh my god thank you
thank you based wood floor all right now
I see a lot cleric [ __ ] at Makkah phone
the 90s are just up my anus right now
yeah haha yeah I'm the best around
nothing really ever came Mina I'm the
man [ __ ] I fell down goddamn it just for
gays ice Oh for lab my god we're but to
wear em Oh another note what did Shrek
right this time take my candle with you
oh thanks thanks you know what I could
have done that many times before but
since the text told me Oh
disappeared oh my [ __ ] god this is
the most useless light I have ever seen
it doesn't lit up [ __ ] and even if it
dead it would probably not smell good
because the letting up [ __ ] doesn't
smell good
alright maybe we can do something here
that doesn't have a door I serve the
great beard or the demo enter the full
gamble be available 2013 oh my god did
you hear that Scully 2014 I can't wait
that long
onda Sora Dussehra does anyone even
juice dioxin use it multiple times
Callie don't be rude Jessica steam has
become a dumping playground as Amida
Sora has lost value
don't look at me like that I know what
you're thinking I'm not a skank you made
out with Billy not me you know what I'm
out of here
all right that was fantastically lame I
think that was pretty lame wasn't it how
do I get the demo version that was
really an innovative game go ahead leave
a like if you enjoy watching brass hits
the sky come read today I see you bros
the next one stay awesome man